slovenia  where the forces of nature  have crafted rich landscapes primed for  adventure  snowy peaks  [Music]  rolling hills  pristine rivers  and steep cliffs  invite us to play  [Music]  in winter these glacier-carved limestone  mountains lure the adventurous  as they have for centuries  by summer alpine ridges and meadows  emerge  leading us along high trails  [Music]  and through hidden valleys  mineral-rich rivers with challenging  rapids  carve down through the topography  a landscape filled with old-growth  forests covering the slopes of the green  hills  [Music]  high above  karst cliffs and caves call out to those  who wish to brave the fight against  gravity  through the seasons these forces  continue to work  always shaping this unique outdoor  playground  you